cazzo vuoi per l'appunto come ti dicevo
e così che ridono gli etero mai etero ed
è da lì che poi ho perso ma solamente se
vuole dare rombo di tuono
[Musica]
ciao ragazzi benvenuti a una puntata di
vita buttata oggi mi faccio un tè con
maurizio merluzzo ciao sono maurizio
merluzzo e sono molto contento di essere
qui oggi senti io l'abbiamo se chiedo
sempre tutti i miei ospiti è niente
posso offrirti qualcosa da bere
volentieri che cos'è che mi gradisce
data l'ora un whisky leggero che schifo
qui
[Musica]
c'è un iceberg una zolletta 2 farei le
do 27 volentieri
mentre invece io scusa al volo mi faccio
qualcosa più di
una ragazzina entra ad un cane non
doveva entrare questo cane
ti prego non può essere anno al culto si
può fermare il tempo trattenendo il
respiro esatto lui aprendo l'anno avremo
culto ora questa epoca bocca trovava
un'altra volta ma queste cose tutte le
prepari allora ti svelo un segreto
io ho praticamente un algoritmo interno
io c'ho una parola che richiama un
algoritmo per cui già nel cassetto 12
amica sito 12 di nico la minchiata
alcune volte le invento e te ne accorgi
perché rido anch'io perché vuol dire che
non la sapevo quel volto un'altra ottica
era già si lavora già detta su la grecia
resta quinto è visto nemmeno ride per un
secondo me eravamo in due invece io so
che tu hai un giorno pazzesco se ti
chiedo
come chiameresti un gesù gesù castro
gesù castoro il cristo redentore
questa è proprio così che ridono gli
etero ho immaginato mi si sbrighi
riempita di vodka misses quid alla tua
lorizio garanzia ancora grazie a te
partiamo con una nuova puntata
di vita buttata volevo farlo fare la
famosa bevuta volevo fare così alla tua
alla tua iniziamo con una nuova puntata
[Musica]
di vita bucata
massimo partes che non sai bono si
annuncia un ospite non è raccontato
l'episodio è successo un po
di giocare a buttarsi dalla finestra
decidiamo di giocare a votare
allora decidiamo di giocare a buttarsi
dalla finestra
agiamo in serra insomma si inizia
gennari ci si buttano dalla finestra e
poi si risaliva dalla terrazza e così
pianto altre volte sappiamo tutti che la
terrazza è il soffitto del palazzo in
toscana la terrazza e il balcone
non lo interrompe rom aiuto movimento
finché a un certo punto io la brillante
idea di dare una piccola spinta mio
fratello come cantù rno successivo lui
si vendica mi dà una spinta astra forte
io al gancio il figlio di panni con i
due denti davanti
e duramente fortunatamente than the road
al latte però io sono rimasta una
minestra 3 20 per un annetto mamma mia
racconti incisivi
ma non fu altre novità io ce l'ho un
aneddoto simile è avvenuto tra fratelli
appunto allora io sono cinque anni più
grande di mia sorella minore certo sono
più grande lei minore ricordo che ero
piccole c'è la mia sorella nel nel
girello e io ero in camera di mio
fratello che aveva appunto un letto e
una scrivania e guardavo mia sorella nel
girello avevo 5 anni 5 anni e mezzo
ricordavo la scrivania guardavo mia
sorella e guardavo la scrivania e penso
ma ci passa sotto
quindi prendo mia sorella e la lanciò
contro la scrivania non c'è praticamente
questo una craniata allucinante comincia
a piangere mia madre corre arriva che è
successo nel 7 turno so peccato contro
la scrivania e lui ce la merda eri tu
che la mia vendetta più grande può
essere uno infamata sovrappeso e un mio
amico mi dava sta perdendo peso quindi
l'ho chiamato a casa gli ho detto ma fra
una settimana venne a casa mia a
mangiare mi ha fatto del tratto con la
besciamella e con i funghi mi sono per
una settimana negli or sono ho dentro
infatti quando ci ha mica detto sa di
cappella ha detto sono i funghi
ti giuro
si
usa questa che è una cosa che ho
scoperto vagliando un tuo video anche
per tu hai una famiglia una grossa parte
della famiglia di mese allora parlava
bene avere ancora chiara io questa cosa
in realtà perché da quando appunto solo
su youtube o una grande fanbase maschile
che mi apprezza sotto molti punti di
vista e non
non tralascia mai la possibilità di di
farmelo dimenticare ti rende però conto
che all'interno di questo assioma non ha
senso che tu ti becchi questo ea me
arrivano delle freni e
stratosferiche agiamo una collaborazione
con faccia una partnership per internato
nella mia psicologia non arriva una
mischia a me 7 giro le mie tette guarda
guarda lì questo impazzendo lui tu in
parte c quando ti dico che mi ridono
[ __ ] vero
[Risate]
ovvero quando capitava che con un amico
ci tenevamo a casa sua ma scusate ma
come mai una promessa come lo è per
l'appunto come ti dicevo quella che ti
racconto più che onesto e di sfiga una
storia di merda ovvero quando capitava
anche con un amico ci radunavano a casa
sua per studiare insieme un giorno
capito che era un certo punto orario
tardo degli le monial esce a fare un
giro restava al secondo piano di questa
palazzina in cui c'è un passamano e le
scale di legno ok con una superficie
praticamente sembra niente esistono le
nomine praticamente ci appoggiamo tutti
e due al passamano e mentre scende a un
certo punto si bloccò appresso lui pure
vi blocca e chiedermi che cosa fosse
successo di tiro verso di me
effettivamente nella mano aveva della
cacca ti ricordi mary poppins quando
secondo me cagava mentre infatti una
volta arrivata giudice va a voi la
scelta a me la scelta che
l'unico modo possibile per in una
spiaggia in visti sono capitato dove in
realtà c'erano molte persone che si
accoppiavano morale della favola ci ha
lasciato una cacata li
guarda quelli che scova
più che una storia la mia un'avventura
avrò avuto 13 14 anni io sono originario
della provincia di foggia io sono nato e
cresciuto in toscana nei miei genitori
sono i migranti dal suo modello di un
paesino piccolissimo una provincia di
fuori si chiama anzano di puglia nei
paesi limitrofi il 16 luglio si
festeggia la madonna del carmine quindi
si va in pellegrinaggio a piedi durante
la notte per arrivare poi il mattino e
sono tipo 15 16 km mi faccio questi 15
16 chilometri per arrivare lì arrivo lì
con i miei amici sacchi a pelo e tutto
quanto devo kakà io per terra e
nell'erba non chicago sono tornato
indietro
facendo un certo punto autostop
sono tornato a casa il 15 chilometri
perché andare nel tuo bagno perché non
ti potevi un attimo sono tornato
indietro ho pagato e sono ritornato li
facendo vari autostop autostop la cosa
meno raccomandabili dovevo pagare ma
quanto ci ha messo tra ritornare
indietro di andare a due tre ore ma io
non l'avrei mai fatta
allora ho
allora maurizio dimmi tu sei famoso per
la sua voce per la mia voce quindi
abbiamo deciso di fare un gioco nel
quale tra togliamo bello dovrai
scegliere un numero a vedere quello che
delineare e farlo indovinare a tutti
loro io inizio col 6 perché tipo la mia
maglia
è una canzone non puoi parlare
[Musica]
cazzo di cane ok ci provo inglese
titoli bilesa ok
del passato a
girare bravissimo bravissimo tasca la
giacca jeans scuro
io scelgo il numero della mia mania di
pallavolo 11 pro capite quando indicato
il
primo bocce crispo sen sessuale bensì
come maurizio è composto da otto lettere
e merluzzo è composto da otto lettere
un'apologia
prendo ais fisar ais
so
lo so
sauber
leggo
una settimana spiegato ha capito che
siamo bravi avevo credo che sei bravo
quando non esagerare no qui guardare
aspettare
il ritorno al futuro
ciao bravo
bravissimo
pessimo paolo
brividi
interno
bravo volano sempre sta prendendo
basilea si leva
in forma grazie
a
questo mi risulta però bravo tanto poco
tempo questa battuta che ha fatto
perdere interno 12 secondi
anche
nicolò possa aver mai baciato un anfora
canzone serie mese
singh e spies che domani
forse
[Applauso]
bravissimo casa bello bello
fate
bene
[Musica]
ma deadpool ricrescono gli organi sì lui
si rigenera ma pazzesco questo tempo
quando è generata raccontato nei
[Risate]
ring
mamma mia
secondo me in realtà non abbiamo vinto
noi sinceramente vinto lui conto proprio
ma io da solo se inglese quadro
rotolare
mamma via
alessandro non posso dirti una cosa tra
guglielmo scilla e maurizio merluzzo
secondo me
dicevamo muto come un merluzzo lo vince
alessandro celi per conto
del cazzo di
cura ma che sam pandev a riceverlo
ma sai quante volte ci scherza se magari
mi capita in altri post di magari
qualcuno che mi pubblica e dice racconta
ma è etero
e tu non lo scrivi nel profilo però che
sei etero che cazzo vuoi se tu non metti
nella descrizione profilo di instagram
una cosa quella cosa non esiste si
materializza nel momento in cui tu chi
la scrive un mio conoscente tentò in
tutti i modi per gelosia di farla
rovinare il rapporto tra me il mio
migliore amico inventando la qualunque
beh io e me la mia vendetta al suo
compleanno mi invitò per fare pace io
andai ma portai con me una bottiglia di
kuta laxer per chi non lo sapesse è un
potente lassativo e lo misi in tutte le
bevande disponibili né di offerta
una cosa se oltre cento invitati devono
correre tutti in bagno e i bagni
disponibile in una villa sono tre che
cosa succede che per quanta merda
possono fare la più grande merda sei tu
perché gli ospiti non si trovano niente
c'entravano nulla che tu non hai
rovinato la festa al tuo amico hai
rovinato la serata a 100 persone con una
mia amica volevamo organizzare un party
con delle persone che erano di un gruppo
c sarà molto sul cazzo infilare il
guttalax ovunque e creare quella che si
chiamava operazione coppa malù
perciò la panna è certo avevamo già
pensato anche a quella bellissima noi
dovevamo staccare l'acqua in modo che
non si poteva più scaricare a quel punto
tutti gli invitati si sarebbero lanciati
a cagare l'anima dentro allo stesso
mater e alla fine il poveretto che il
padrone di casa che era quello che forse
fa più antipatico persona avrebbe pulito
vomitando sopra che faceva la panna ma
lui ho riso così tanto all'idea di
incallita di che non ho più sentito il
bisogno di farlo fantastico cioè tu hai
concretizzato tutto nella tua mente
pienamente perché è così divertente
l'idea anche raccomandano fatta fine ma
scontiamo l'ultima cena in onore di
feste a me non mi invitavano mai dato da
ragazzino e rossi catello bruciato ed è
da lì che poi ha detto ora vado in
palestra di fatto tutti allora io da
ragazzino ho fatto tante arti marziali
ho dovuto smettere drasticamente tra gli
11 ei 13 anni sono cresciuto di 30 cm in
due anni quindi la schiena non ha retto
e io ho dovuto lasciare le arti marziali
tutto quello che facevo anzi faceva
ginnastica riabilitativa
in realtà la prima chiave perché mi ha
permesso di uscire dall essere pulita
perché è molto magro molto secco con
l'apparecchio con i brufoli è stata la
voce non è stato il fisico il fisico è
venuto dopo perché facevo le imitazioni
dei professori facevo limitazioni dei
personaggi e quindi venivo preso in
simpatia
magari da quelli un po più figli della
scuola ed essendo simpatico allora
essendo amico loro venivo preso molto
meno di mira fino a che non sono più
stato preso di mira racconta
non ho mai provato tutti due stampi lui
pensa che sia nato un po troppo forte
sono tenuti come funziona che come
ferendo
[Risate]
maurizio
maurizio grazie lì c'è alessandro di
rete o la crisi spero che al sappi che
quando fai ridere lui sono meno due
punti
questa è una cosa fondamentale invece
perché educazione sessuale per tutte le
persone che ci ascoltano il sesso è un
qualcosa che
tendenzialmente più facile per un uomo
l'uomo a un organo anche la donna non sa
che è la prostata esatto vai a toccare
una zona erogena che gli uomini hanno le
donne non ce l'hanno va bene dare il
rombo di tuono assolutamente sì ma
solamente se vuole dare rombo di tuono e
nessuno là fuori no nessun vi deve far
sentire che dovete darvi rombo di tuono
perché voi il rombo di tuono non lo
dovete a nessuno ah no
con questo ringrazio maurizio merluzzo
grazie per le sue perle ecco che sono
merluzzo fosse stata una nostri che però
hanno è la perfetta c'è ti potevi alzare
da tavola da signore hai ragione e
invece devo sempre strafare miei ragazzi
naturalmente ci rivediamo non so quando
ma sempre all'interno di questo canale
cauto
fate un
doppiaggio dall'inter sarà il rombo di
tuono
ricercato una cronaca non c'è presso e
un cappellino dati e rombo di tuono il
rombo di tuono credo che longo di fondo
sia la mia nuova parola preferita
ho maturato il rombo di tuono è billy se
un superpotere tikhonov agghiaccianti le
ragazze naturalmente tutti quanti voi
commentate con rombo di tuono qua sotto
ma anche sotto i canali i canali
moriggia ma che isna che rimandi il
socio che parte saranno commentate con
il rombo di tuono esatto po ovunque
spalmatelo
e
[Musica]